in case you missed pgl major Krakow 2017
no worries because we got you covered
here were the top 10 plays from this
major coming in at number ten is Rob
since 8:00 where he manages to take out
every member of faith plan to win the
round
well that's the babe will find up you
back there that way that's quite nice
for a total mb8 yeah we'll get so
excited considering it'll clock stopped
still very well you will I like your
lousy thank you
our ninth spot goes to fanatics lusha
and his crisp clean lock
glasha is definitely pop there as a
clutch player much player - yes now
would be one hell of a time to bring
that quality to life
he has no needs and Guardians got the
angle here unbelievable hit the head
shot regardless and now into the 1v1
sees is holding close to the connector
will flush will be able to figure this
out
these two have an idea of it that could
be lurking I got a big head start what's
up lipstick let's go grabbing the 8th
spot its way Landers echoey to win the
round for flipside tactics the deal with
this bush well I'm magnifica the first
one second as well so oh my god way
Landa poor kills just like that with a
single pistol they definitely messed
that up and now crystal coming down the
ramp in a one versus three way Lander
going for the clutch the ACE here as
well gonna get a spray in your oh oh
five kills just like that stealing the
seventh spot is skadoodle perfect one
before clutch we sponsor out sooner than
shroud good approach and pounce good
shot from skadoodle but round over on
the Freid bigs going to make this ten
one only Wednesday because he's now
picked up a gun he's got armor to work
with smokes gonna bounce the wrong way
when he's in the high HP player keep
down could do have got nothing in it
he's got an argument in this day say in
the argument perhaps as god be 16 HP
goes hunting he's look the wrong way
this is all skadoodle this is all timing
schedules to lose bombers in the hands
of golf B now the fact that he's rated
to drop her he likely expects us to
doodle come back around coming in six
exhibits is insane one b3 to win the
round for a strap closer leaves it mixed
it'll be back-to-back rounds for G 2
unless he can clutch it he's no word
he's got the first shot and he got the
second as well six on inferno never
ceases to amaze that's so sick what was
that shot our fifth spot goes to
electronic who fights for his team with
a one before clutch against fnatic this
is JW's round three kills for half a
lineup for electronic toe and a 1v2 and
another one what we won all of you knows
exactly where electronic is playing from
electrons you still got nine bullets in
the mag and will they find the shot the
pressure is on here for hole advisor and
all of my fries out of 23 a tree
this is electronic fighting for it a
penny will get the clock to the end on
believable coming in fourth is hobbits
God light 1 2 3 clutch against immortals
to win the round setup getting torn
apart back in again the first kill on
the way through you can suck out all the
time
grabbing the third spot is called dara'a
and plainly precise off ace against big
top MIT and all the way over toward
atrium taps and goes quite cold here as
quicker get that second as well as the
ball will go down and follows it up
through all lining up Gould here or with
the names a beautiful one as well and
he's elated for good reason grabbing our
second spot is doe just sneaky 200 IQ
grenades against immortals during the
grand final morsels now feeling like
they know what the deuce of challenges
in our position the gambit is send even
more firepower that ring boy getting so
sergeant orbits use Georgie's gonna made
into the corner get to the critical job
our number one spot goes to Papa Pasha's
unbelievable one before clutching where
he manages to wind around with a sliver
of health rolls down to connectors as
the first kill something to build upon
but not believing just yet against the
devil offset all right now is going to
jump as the site to work with Lucas or
just barely goes under the cross let's
walk see buddy what do I want what a
shot from back to thick a tree Flint has
open as he possibly there in the site
and how does he choose to approach it
fail dak because they know he was down
to near one-shot wonder he's gone to
work CP
[Applause]
fans will urge him over and he's going
to be updated he's going to go over a
doctor back he just came from there this
was the one versus four to play of
passes life it planets so open hand he's
going to have no idea smokes goes onto
it he's not picking it yet passion he's
patient and he fought it you know
the plow got real life skill no gas will
roll backgrounds I've ever deeper his
entire career that is brilliant
those were our top 10 picks for the
major what was your favorite play let us
know in the comments below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button